your big locks this week locks for the
week we're going we're going Kyle Allen
to the house Panthers
we're going Panthers spread Ravens by
the hook you need the hook and then
lastly you're going to gonna we're going
Jets oh but we're going jet to the house
so you like the Jets the Panthers and
the Ravens why did you choose those twos
mainly because Lamar Jackson's on is on
a run Peter he's gonna go off Kyle Allen
is the truth wave out of Camp Nou Tain's
taken over and then lastly Jets are just
on and on a tear
all right Marco well we're rooting for
you hopefully it works out and if not
then you can go get some deep dish back
in Chicago I guess so thank you very
much sink Redman all right brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three icons continue to impress millions
skillfully reversing time and
outperforming younger men the Irishman's
cast of Robert DeNiro Al Pacino and
director Martin Scorsese aras masterful
as Tom Brady drew brees and Bill
Belichick all Hall of Famers who light
up the screen with varying degrees of
gangster
she is our gangster this is the V R
Betty show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book and happy
Thanksgiving weekend are vetting insider
Kelly Pesci Stewart I'm cabby Richards
you never got lined up I haven't seen
that movie yet but I know it's as long
as a football game and it's got to be
more entertaining than watching the
Cowboys right now no special effects
needed for my best bets 9 2 and 1 on the
season and we're ready off to a hot
start for week 13 if you're following
along on social you saw the 2o & 1 we
went on Thanksgiving the rest of my week
13 pics are on the way let's go caddy
yeah
[Music]
let's kick things off with the marquee
matchups of the week let's head over to
Sunday Night Football Patriots - three
versus the Texans total 46 and a half
we've talked about this before Bill
Belichick owns his former assistant Bill
O'Brien five and host straight off
against him but New England's kind of on
cruise control right now but I promise
you guys I wouldn't bet against the
Patriots just yet I do lean towards the
Texans here though Monday Night Football
we have the Vikings plus three at the
Seahawks total of 50 is Seattle the real
deal I'm not so sure Seattle just one in
five to get to spend their last six
games as a home favorite I'm rocking
with my favorite 80s coach that's right
coach Zimmer and the Vikings plus three
the 49ers currently five and a half here
at Caesar's Palace versus the Ravens
total 45 and a half we have the number
one defense versus the number one office
this may be a Super Bowl preview and of
course I have a best bet on this game
but you guys are gonna have to wait till
the end of the show here is a quick
recap of the marquee matchups I do like
the Vikings I lean towards detectives
and as I mentioned I have a best bet in
the 49ers Ravens coming right up the
Raven since Madden 20 has increased
Lamar Jackson speed Howdy's it's not
cabby you know it's really interesting
because here I am with Madden 2014 still
in the wrapper so no I'm a little behind
that dude is faster than you can talk
your way out of a speeding ticket both
Kelly Stewart and Lamar Jackson are
cheat codes in real life that's a big
fact another speed demon who plays in
Kansas City and in the latest
installment of expert analysis Warren
sharp tells us why Tyreke Hill and the
Chiefs have caught his eye this weekend
what do we know about and Urey we know
he's really good with extra time to
prepare true super good ok now I just
looked back looked up right now what
he's done against the Raiders since he's
came to Kansas City in 2014 and he's
nine and two and seven and four against
the spread both of those losses the two
losses were games on Thursdays for an
average margin of victory there okay so
the average margin of victory is in the
non Thursday game
is 15.2 God and 550 long sharp and Adam
left go you can catch them together on
social at left go show Kelly what are
you still in this matchup Chino and
Raiders warrants not the only one who
likes the Chiefs too cheap so opened
here at Caesars as nine and half point
favorites lines up to 11 this morning
I'm not looking to fade Warren here but
I'm also not rushing to lay the points
with the Chiefs just two and seven
against a spread their last nine home
games but let's take a look at few games
and I am wanting to bet on today it's
right we have the Bucks - 3 at the
Jaguars total 46 and a half
I'm just confused here because here I am
betting the Bucks every week and now you
guys want to back Jameis Winston as a
road favorite this line is way too high
Tampa Bay though has gone over nine of
their last game so keep an eye on the
total but I'm rocking with the Jags the
home dogs plus three Jets - 3 at the
bengals 42 and a half is the total here
I said early on in the week this was the
trap game of the year when the Jets were
three and a half point road favorites I
understand this team is clicking right
now but it doesn't matter they should
not be favorites even the Bengals Plus
Zack Taylor brought back this man why
cuz he doesn't a big doughnut next to
his first season and neither does Chad
Johnson so we're rocking with the
Bengals plus three the Browns
two and a half point road favorites that
the Steelers total 39 and a half so this
one's interesting because of a weird
scheduling I don't know I won't call it
a debacle but it is weird this seems to
just play two weeks ago on Thursday
night and the Browns absolutely owned
the Steelers both teams missing key
players but Mike Tomlin 32 and 20
against the spread is an underdog went
to Devlin Hodges over Mason Rudolph and
I think that actually is the right move
I like the Steelers plus two and a half
cabby and that is my card for week 13
random Mike Tomlin sound bikes like
splash anyway phase four of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe was announced this
summer and a photo from the set of Black
Panther 2 leaked since this cat what was
luck sorry since cat escaped from
Lokhande and sauntered onto the field at
MetLife Stadium on November 4th cat
teams in the NFL are o and 12 and 3 8
and 1 against the spread kill mongers
out here looking for vibranium and baby
Yoda Kelly are you sure you want to back
the Jaguars and the Bengals this week
this is the funniest thing I've heard I
saw it on our social pages this morning
and no I don't take the team's mascots
into account while betting them plus we
got the cover with the Lions so we're
already want to Noah gets to spread this
week we do shout out to Duvall eleven on
reddit for the statuses and that's what
we do here at be our underscore betting
or although we gave you all of the
latest gambling trends and cat meetings
when our audience isn't distracted by
all the Black Friday deals they have
times it's time to send us our biggest
their biggest betting questions here now
are the minds of the public a Lawrence
wants to know the Packers are they
covering - six and a half Kelly you know
this one looks like the public play of
the week we'll leave it at that but you
have to watch this early reverse line we
made it move down to six
because the short guys are buying on the
Giants that's where I got the Giants a
lot of people are looking at the weather
and this one as well but keep in mind as
long as there's no wind both
quarterbacks should be able to air it
out but I am not laying points with
Aaron Rodgers and that defense right now
I can't do it
so maroc with Daniel Jones and the six
and a half at home at Danny dumps or
Dida hunch Sports asks what NFL late
season dark horse
do you see making a run if any to the
Super Bowl that nobody's talking about
you know we just talked about this team
during the marquee matchups and it's the
Vikings their 13 to one here at Caesar's
Palace and you get a better number
around town we've talked about this
before I love coach Zimmer great 80s
coach great coats overall I know Kirk
Cousins is not exactly a Super Bowl
winning quarterback but there is some
value with the third best team in the
NFC and Devon Cook has been devouring
defenses recently world from we call it
the itis hits you like 35 minutes after
you consume about 7 pounds of food so
now that you're awake from your
tryptophan induced coma from Thursday
enjoy feasting on Kelly's best bet
[Music]
last week we cashed again laying three
with San Francisco improving our season
record - nine - and one on best bets I'm
running it back again this week with the
Niners plus five and a half I just had
some guy before the show go how are you
gonna fade Lamar Jackson don't you know
what happened on Monday Night Football
yeah brah I know I gotta have a short
memory here as a sports bettor and I'm
gonna tell you why because right now the
Ravens just sitting pretty
everybody loves the Ravens but they're
about to face the best defense they've
seen all year hey sorry Patriots fans I
hate to break it to you the Niners are
the best defense in the league we're
gonna lay it with the night we're gonna
take the points with the Niners and
don't forget sprinkle just a little bit
on that money line let's recap all of my
picks for week 13 these are lists an
order of confidence on how many units
I'd recommend you bet on each so I we're
gonna for you to play on the 49ers three
units on the Vikings and Jags we've also
got a couple of units on the Bengals
Steelers and Giants one guy that won't
be fading or following your picks this
week as Cardinals defensive back Josh on
Friday was suspended indefinitely
through the 2020 season for betting on
NFL games this season a league
investigation determined that no games
were compromised Kelly what do you make
of the story I mean the guy was on IR he
was probably really bored and just
wanted a little bit action I can't fault
the guy and also everybody needs a
friend like Kelly Stewart thank you for
streaming the B are betting show on the
Bleacher Report app on YouTube and
Twitter it has been presented by the
Caesars Palace Sports Club be sure to
follow along on social IBR underscore
betting for all of my picks good luck on
your bets and let's have a profitable
Sunday
[Music]